I've never let go of my vision to commit
to the commitment is very powerful it is
only try to do one thing at a time
the motivation
what's a top 10 with believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a woman who went
from being an anthropology student to
dropping out of school to become an
actress to becoming an Academy
award-winning actress and successful
entrepreneur she's Gwyneth Paltrow and
here is my take on her top ten rules of
success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take risks you know for me I took a
crazy risk you know I really did have a
perfectly good day job and I was really
going well it was going great I aren't
you nervous like what you really like
scared to jump in or what were you
feeling like was it scared but I had
self belief and that's what I think you
know ultimately because people knock you
down all the time and they poke holes
and they don't like this about your
business model and they don't believe in
you and you know you just have to keep
getting back up and getting back up and
getting back up and I think what got me
through was this I've never let go of my
vision it's like I just see a bull's eye
and it might be really really far away
but I'm like going straight for it and
doing the best I can and but in the
meantime you know I'm building a really
interesting business rule number two a
value time what's the best piece of
advice you've ever been given that you
keep with you to this day my dad gave me
the best advice like pertaining to every
situation in my 20s I was having trouble
with one of my girlfriends who like you
know known since grade school and he
said you can't make new walls
and it really stuck with me and now
that's actually a piece of ice think you
can apply it to other things too but
it's like the value in time you know
it's sort of like what you were saying
with cash like the value that's created
when two people make a commitment
whether it's a relationship or a
friendship or a parent-child
relationship to commit to the commitment
is very powerful it is very powerful
rule number three like yourself what is
the single most important thing that
changed that you're grateful that you
made when it comes to your own wellness
I think deciding that I liked myself and
that I didn't really ultimately like it
didn't serve me what other people's
opinions were of me good or bad whatever
that projection was really wasn't
serving me and I think you know I think
around the time that I turned 40 I
really I felt like I got a software
upgrade and I was like oh I couldn't
like myself and I kind of like you know
what I mean I and and I think it's a
real blessing and I think everybody when
they turn 40 gets this software upgrade
and it's sort of it's it's been an
incredible blessing and I think you know
because with that has come a lot of self
acceptance and forgiveness and being
present and open and not fighting so
hard against this idea of what I thought
I was supposed to be or where I was
supposed to be or what kind of marriage
I was supposed to have or X Y & Z you
know I've really accepted myself and
that I think I feel so much better
having done that then you know I did
from doing yoga and eating macrobiotic
food rule number four build something
you believe in has anything surprised
you about being an entrepreneur like
before you came in you like you decided
to fuller throw yourself all in anything
surprise to you about this experience I
mean so many things surprised me i I I
had no idea what I was getting into I
had no I
how much I didn't know and how much
there was to learn I had no idea how
much like I was in a career where
everyone kissed my ass and now people
are like you like what's the bottom line
you know now I'm like on JetBlue I'm
like yeah but honestly I'm I've I've
never felt so professionally fulfilled
in my life and it's such a grind and
it's such hard work but it's so amazing
to be building something that you
believe in and making product that you
love and putting it into the world and
getting feedback positive and negative
and sorting through it I just I'm just I
much prefer it even though no one kisses
my ass rule number five learn how to
deal with criticism so this is what
Martha Stewart said about Quinn with a
couple of weeks ago this is well before
the Lisa announcement and in fact she
just needs to be quiet and she's a movie
star if she were confident in her acting
she wouldn't be trying to be Martha
Stewart first of all no one has ever
said anything bad about me before
shocked and devastated I'll try to
recover
you know if I'm really honest I am so
psyched that she sees us as competition
I'm so excited I think that when anybody
criticizes anyone it really is just it's
revealing more about where they are in
time and space as opposed to where you
are and time and space and I think
generally we tend to you know lash out
if we're in a you know what I mean it's
usually a reflection of something else
and so I try not to I don't actually at
this point in my life I don't I don't
take it personally I see it as a as a
projection and you know and then if
there's ever anything you know that
sticks then I know oh maybe I'm holding
this judgment against myself and I need
to look at that but it's it's it's very
interesting and you know sometimes I
learn good things from criticism so rule
number six start small I want to know
about the first time you set your
fingertips to keyboard and decided to
start a weekly newsletter it really kind
of came about in a very small way like
me and my kitchen with my girlfriends
like talking about ideas and then what
started to happen was essentially there
was a trust that started to get built
between myself and my readers and there
was a lot of traction that started to
happen if I recommended something that I
found or that I loved then I was
starting to you know have this amazing
feedback from these businesses saying
this has a real measurable big impact
and I was like oh wow that's interesting
and so it was kind of all piece by piece
you know it was a very slow very organic
process over years and I've been doing
it for a time until I started started to
think well I wonder how I wonder how I
would do this if I wanted to turn it
into a business if I wanted to monetize
it do I want to do that what I ever have
advertising would I ever sell anything
what would I sell and the process just
you know it just was a slow evolution
rule number seven learned through trial
and error you know was the transition
going from a huge Hollywood actress
huge star to entrepreneur how did you
how did you learn did you kind of seek
mentors just kind of learn by trial and
error a lot of trial and error a lot of
epic mistakes or some epic mistakes you
made you know just like there are
thousand I mean like for example not
understanding you know not understanding
the importance of doing your own due
diligence whether it's on hiring someone
I'd be like oh everybody you know they
seem great well fine you know you might
want to check or you know switching
email service providers like what might
this entail and like I had a huge
problem recently when I did that because
I just didn't do the research and I
didn't know now I know rule number eight
do one thing at a time the thing that
I've learned that's helped me the most
is that I only try to do one thing at a
time
so you know if I'm picking up my kids in
school I'm not trying to also make
decisions about that I do both badly so
I really try to carve out my time well
rule number nine
listen kindly and openly so you talked
about the fact that you've had some
separation between being an actress and
being a much more but there must be some
skills that you're able to take from
being an actress to becoming an
entrepreneur and I was wondering what
those were oh that's a really good
question nobody's ever asked me that
before I think you know there are more
interpersonal skills like when you're
acting with somebody you know like
listening respect kind of being a
container I think you know establishing
that kind of rapport and respect for
people and listening kindly and openly
those sort of skills that help you be a
good actress I think help you in in
business because in my experience you
know they create more points of
connection and when you work with people
and you have the capacity to listen and
you have the respect back and forth you
know the best of that person starts to
emerge and it's been amazing you know I
have like my girls that I love
much and to see them you know grow and
create roles for themselves and then
fill the roles in the business it's it's
amazing and I think I do think that
comes from a very specific type of
listening that you you learn from acting
and rule number ten the last time before
a very special bonus clip is have fun
never ever I have I lied to get a job
[Music]
[Applause]
never ever have I gotten out of a
speeding ticket by being a celebrity
never ever have I forgotten the name of
a date like like while you're with them
I don't understand that what else give
all your with them with them that would
be really horrific never ever have I
seen one of my Mordecai's co-stars naked
[Applause]
never ever have I lied on a talk show
[Applause]
never ever have I sexted yeah no I
haven't done that never ever have I said
a baby was cute when it was obviously
ugly
I ride have got a very special bonus
clip from Gweneth on how to try things
and the importance of it that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life in business
so here we go question number one how
can you just start small today on your
big dreams number two what is a risk you
are going to take this week and number
three what habits will you build in to
like yourself regularly
and I think you know my whole sort of
road towards wellness started my father
was diagnosed with cancer when I was
about 26 and that's when I started
reading about environmental toxins and
the connection between food and cancer
and stress and cancer and so I really
started to become obsessive about you
know in an in a vain effort to heal him
kind of by proxy because he really
wasn't that interested in health food I
remember I was you know trying to go
make him go gluten-free and dairy-free
and sugar-free and I spent all day
making these muffins cuz you know he all
he wanted was to feel normal after his
cancer and I made these muffins with you
know I don't know coconut sugar and
whatever kind of flour and he bit into
one and I was like how what do you think
and he said it's like biting into the
New York Times so he was among the first
who was sort of critical of my forays
into wellness you know I think that I I
remember once I had acupuncture and
cupping which is an ancient yes China
technique and there was this big uproar
in the press and I was a witch and I was
you know what was I doing or when I
started doing yoga 20 years ago you know
the press had a field day with that and
and I've just sort of over by pattern
wrecking the recognition realized that
you know I'm somebody who likes to try
things and then people think I'm insane
and then now there's a yoga place on
every corner and yeah you know now
people that no one eats gluten anymore
if I've talked to one person who's been
successful they all say at some point
people ridiculed them criticized them
thought they were nuts and I think that
that it's really important that if you
believe in your idea if you have an
ability to shut that out you can
persevere raise your standard Apple at
the pool
core value is that we believe that
people have passion can change the way
people now one drop of myself work
depends on your it's suppose to mean
if you guys like this video check out
the top ten we did on Jessica Alba it's
right next to me I think you're gonna
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I spent a lot of time in
my head fantasizing about being a
superhero
and about being somebody else and what
would it be like to live